Trascrizione: Cecilia Negri
Revisore: Beatrice Chiamenti
(Musica)
Grazie, buongiorno.
Quindi, dalle stelle alla Terra.
Io avevo 38 anni,
2 figlie e un bel lavoro
quando una sera mio marito
è venuto a casa
e mi ha detto:
fra due mesi ci trasferiamo
a vivere negli Stati Uniti.
È stato un bello shock,
anche perché ne avevamo parlato, sì,
ma solo a livello di idea,
non di fatto concreto.
Abbiamo vissuto a Washington DC
per tre anni
Tre magnifici anni, devo dire,
anche se ricordo i primi sei mesi
come un periodo
particolarmente difficile.
Quando l'esperienza è finita
ho voluto capire meglio
che cosa mi era successo
e, studiando, ho realizzato
che quello che era accaduto a me,
sorpresa sorpresa,
accade a tutti quelli che
si trasferiscono all'estero.
E di quel periodo
ho imparato una lezione
che oggi condivido con voi,
e cioè che adattarsi è più facile
che resistere.
Quanti di voi hanno mai pensato
di trasferirsi all'estero
per lavoro, studio o,
semplicemente,
per cercare un altro posto dove vivere?
Parecchi.
Bene.
Questa è la mia casa di Washington.
E questo è il paesaggio a cui
eravamo abituati.
Siete in buona compagnia perchè
sono oltre 4 milioni e 200 mila
gli italiani
che oggi
vivono all'estero,
circa il 7,3% della popolazione italiana.
Quindi numeri non piccoli.
Andare a vivere all'estero è
una grande opportunità
una straordinaria avventura,
un elemento di arricchimento
a tutte le età.
Ma è anche una grande sfida
a cui arrivare preparati.
Perchè quando l'occasione diventa concreta
oltre all'entusiasmo,
cominciano le paure,
le ansie, i dubbi.
Ce la farò ad adattarmi,
a vivere in un paese diverso dal mio?
Ce la farò a imparare una nuova lingua,
nuove abitudini?
A farmi nuovi amici?
E ci preoccupiamo sempre molto
degli aspetti pratici del trasferimento,
trovare una casa, cosa portare
organizzare il trasloco.
In realtà queste sono le cose più facili
da gestire.
Della mia esperienza americana
vi racconto due piccoli episodi,
accaduti all'inizio,
che servono
per introdurre il tema.
Il primo giorno di lavoro
mio marito va a lavorare
e naturalmente,
come si usa in Italia,
si presenta al lavoro
vestito formale,
giacca e cravatta, camicia stirata,
scarpe inglesi.
Il classico gessato.
Salvo arrivare, e trovare un mare
di t-shirt e pantaloni informali
C'è qualcosa che non va.
Il primo sabato sera
alcuni colleghi di lavoro
ci invitano a cena.
Sono molto gentili gli americani,
vogliono subito coinvolgerti.
E naturalmente Sabato sera
andiamo con un abbigliamento rilassato,
un po' casual, salvo scoprire
che gli altri sono vestiti eleganti,
come per una cerimonia.
C'è decisamente qualcosa che non va.
Dopo pochi giorni cominciano
ad arrivare degli inviti,
per delle feste,
siamo in Giugno.
Apro l'invito e penso
"Sarà una festa in giardino,
i nostri vicini ci vogliono coinvolgere
nella piccola comunità
del nostro quartiere.
Apro l'invito e resto scioccata.
C'è scritto: Save the date.
Il nostro party sarà il 10 Novembre,
dalle 19.00 alle 21.00.
E io penso, e se io accetto e poi
il 10 Novembre sono morta,
che figura ci faccio?
E se poi alle 21.00 non me ne vado,
cosa succede?
Mi buttano fuori?
Ma perché si comportano così?
Perchè, come si dice,
è la cultura bellezza.
Il modo di comportarsi delle persone
è determinato dalla loro cultura
e, anche se noi
non ce ne accorgiamo,
il modo in cui noi
ci relazioniamo agli altri
e agiamo nella vita di tutti i giorni,
è condizionato da quello
che abbiamo appreso
fin da bambin,
vivendo in un certo gruppo,
in un certo paese e in un certo,
specifico, momento storico.
Quindi, quando abbiamo a che fare
con altre persone
che vengono da altri paesi,
è inevitabile che ci sia
uno scontro tra culture.
La cultura è sicuramente visibile
nei nostri comportamenti quotidiani,
ma permea la nostra vita
in maniera ancora più profonda.
È legata a tutto quello che noi pensiamo,
facciamo,
al modo in cui ci comportiamo,
ai nostri atteggiamenti,
alle nostre percezioni.
Questa è una cavalletta.
E voi direte, è un semplice animale.
Sì. È un semplice animale.
Ma questo animale è considerato
una piaga in nord America
e in Europa;
è considerato un animale domestico
in molti posti della Cina,
è considerato un ottimo antipasto
in Thailandia.
Se anche un animale così piccolo
è percepito
e costruito nel suo significato
culturalmente,
immaginatevi che cosa succede
con le persone.
Quello che ci succede quando incontriamo
culture diverse dalla nostra
è che subiamo quello che viene definito
il culture shock.
Ma il culture shock non è un evento.
È un processo.
E cerchiamo di vederlo assieme perché
arrivarci preparati
è la cosa più importante.
All'inizio viviamo qualche giorno
in cui tutto sembra irreale.
Siamo appena arrivati
e ci sembra di vivere in un sogno.
Subito dopo abbiamo una fase
di grande entusiasmo.
Si chiama "la luna di miele";
tutto nuovo, eccitante, interessante.
Ci piace scoprire, guardare,
vedere tutto in una luce romantica.
Purtroppo questa fase dura
solo poche settimane.
Dopodichè cominciano i problemi.
Non siamo in vacanza,
siamo lì per restare
e cominciamo a sperimentare
tutte le difficoltà di vivere
in un ambiente che non è il nostro.
Le difficoltà di comunicare con gli altri,
le resistenze, tutto ci sembra irritante,
le persone, il clima,
il cibo, le abitudini.
Finché tocchiamo il fondo.
Abbiamo molti sentimenti negativi,
frustrazione, ansia, paure,
difficoltà, senso di incompetenza,
incomunicabilità.
È difficile vivere da stranieri
in una terra straniera.
E quando siamo in questa fase,
solitamente utilizziamo,
come tutte le persone,
due comportamenti:
gli stereotipi e
l'etnocentrismo.
Gli stereotipi sono ovviamente
delle generalizzazioni,
delle schematizzazioni molto rigide
d caratteristiche che attribuiamo
a un gruppo di persone
anche se in realtà
appartengono a degli individui.
Volete degli esempi?
I tedeschi sono tutti rigidi,
gli svizzeri puntuali,
gli italiani molto romantici,
i francesi arroganti,
gli americani ignoranti.
Ma, a proposito di ignoranza,
voi sapete dov'è Buffalo?
Qualcuno lo sa?
No.
Buffalo è la seconda città più importante
dello stato di New York,
dopo New York City.
Stato di New York.
Vedete, siamo ignoranti anche noi.
Come del resto,
credo che pochi di noi sappiano
qual è la capitale del New Mexico.
Santa Fe.
Oppure dell'Alabama.
Montgomery.
O del Mississipi.
Jackson.
Eppure gli Stati Uniti sono molto più
grandi e popolosi
dell'Europa,
ma noi non lo sappiamo
quali sono le loro capitali.
Ma pensiamo che
gli americani siano ignoranti
Perché spesso non sanno che
Parigi e Bruxelles
non sono entrambe in Francia.
Quindi, gli stereotipi sono facili
da ribaltare.
Un'altra arma che utilizziamo
è l'etnocentrismo.
Cosa facciamo?
Pensiamo che la nostra cultura
sia la migliore.
Etnocentrismo letteralmente
vuol dire
mettere il proprio gruppo al centro.
Attribuire una superiorità intrinseca
al proprio modo di agire,
alla propria cultura.
Noi italiani quando andiamo all'estero
lo facciamo sempre.
Il nostro cibo è migliore
di tutti gli altri,
siamo gli unici a saperci vestire
decentemente al mondo,
il nostro paese è il più bello in assoluto
ma non siamo gli unici a fare questo.
Per tutti è così.
Quello che succede
nella nostra famosa curva
è che una volta superata questa fase
impariamo a risalire.
Impariamo nuove strategie.
Ci facciamo nuovi amici.
Capiamo come comportarci,
e finalmente torna anche
la fiducia in se stessi,
l'equilibrio,
la voglia di stare con gli altri.
Fino a quando ci integriamo,
siamo di nuovo a casa.
Finalmente abbiamo capito
che il paese ospite
è la nostra nuova casa.
Sappiamo distinguere
gli aspetti positivi e negativi
della cultura di origine
e della cultura di partenza.
Tutti quanti passiamo
attraverso questo processo
quando andiamo in un paese straniero.
Ovviamente, questo processo
è più o meno lungo,
più o meno intenso,
a seconda di chi siamo noi,
che esperienze abbiamo precedentemente
e anche di quanto distante è
la cultura di origine da quella di arrivo.
Quello che è importante però,
è conoscere questo processo in anticipo,
esserne consapevoli
per poter affrontare meglio
l'esperienza,
perché, alla fine, adattarsi
è più facile che resistere.
Grazie.
(Musica)